unlike other large school districts
across the country that retain their
superintendents often for decades at a
time the clark county school district
the fifth largest in the entire country
has been through quite a few yeah
tonight kirsten joyce takes a closer
look
we've had 12 different superintendents
since the inception of the clark county
school district in 1956 but just in the
past 20 years five different
superintendents have been in power and
several have definitely clashed with the
school board in 2000 mr carlos garcia
served for a five-year period and left
followed by dr walt rolfes who retired
after serving four years dr dwight jones
resigned in 2013
and then the position went to pat
skorkowski who retired in 2018.
dr jesus jarrah has led ccsd since 2018
that is until he became the first ccsd
superintendent to be fired from the
board this week
now right after dr kenny guin served as
superintendent from 1969 to 1978. the
first black superintendent dr claude
perkins took the helm but after clashing
with the school board he was pressured
to resign after just three years dr
robert wentz surf from 1982-1989
dr brian kram took the district's helm
in 1989 serving for nearly 11 years then
retired in 2000.